NARRATOR: It calls to
mind events that occurred
more than a century
ago, which means
the key to the present
dilemma may lie in the past.
DAN HUBER: Understanding
patterns in historical attacks
can also help us to understand
patterns in current attacks.
NARRATOR: So experts are
turning their attention back,
all the way back to the
very first significant shark
attack spike in US history--
1916, the Jersey Shore,
when terror reigned.
MICHAEL CAPUZZO: The 1916 shark
attacks on the New Jersey Shore
are the greatest shark
attack mystery of all time.
And really, the movie
"Jaws" and the book
would not have been
possible without it.
NARRATOR: Though
people at the time
believed sharks to be
harmless, five beachgoers
are bitten in just two weeks.
Four lose their lives,
causing panic up
and down the Eastern seaboard.
For years, experts have
studied these attacks
and struggled to
explain what happened.
But there is one parallel
between the very first
fatal attack in 1916
and one of the more
recent attacks that might prove
to be more than a coincidence.
They both happened at
similar times of day.
In 1916, the first fatal victim
was bitten around 5:00 PM,
just like Ida Parker.
IDA PARKER: It was about
5:00 in the afternoon.
NARRATOR: And according to
shark expert Dr. Dan Huber,
this may not be mere chance.
DAN HUBER: Recent research
has shown that sharks can use
the angle of the
sun in order to give
them a predatory advantage.
NARRATOR: If a shark is hunting
when the sun is high overhead,
the water is brightly lit
and potential prey can easily
see the shark's approach.
DAN HUBER: It's going
to illuminate the shark.
Perhaps so much so
that it's really
not worth their time to hunt
during the middle of the day.
NARRATOR: But when the
sun is lower in the sky,
like it is around 5:00
PM, everything changes.
To explain, Huber sets
up a demonstration.
DAN HUBER: Here we
have a small lure,
which represents the shark.
Next, we have a GoPro
camera, which represents
the point of view of the prey.
And last, we have the light,
which represents the sun.
NARRATOR: When the sun
is close to the horizon,
sharks approach prey using
a very clever method.
DAN HUBER: They'll position
the sun behind themselves
so if the prey were to look
where the shark is coming from,
it's going to be
blinded by the sun.
As you can see from
the footage, the scene
gets completely washed
out, making it harder
to see the oncoming predator.
NARRATOR: This may be key to
understanding the attacks.
Because due in part
to this camouflage,
sharks often hunt at two
particular times of day.
DAN HUBER: Sharks
will be more actively
hunting during dawn and dusk.
NARRATOR: As a result,
experts the world over advise
beachgoers to avoid
the water both early
and late in the day when they
may run into a hunting shark.
So were beachgoers in 1916
and today simply swimming
during these dangerous times?
Huber examines
the data and finds
that, while most of the
victims in both spikes
were bitten during
the afternoon,
none were bitten
at dawn or dusk.
DAN HUBER: So the idea that this
would have caused the attacks
simply isn't supported.